あ～ごめんごめんごめん
この分け目が大事なんだな多分
髪の毛を戻しました、
はじめしゃちょーです。
はい、と言う訳でですね
髪の毛を・・・あっ
はいというわけでこちらにちょっと無数の
じゃがりこを準備しました
えっと多分この中に今販売されている
じゃがいもじゃないです・・
今多分販売されている
じゃがりこのほとんど全種類があると思われます
じゃがりこチーズ
じゃがりこサラダ
じゃがりこバター
じゃがりこゆず塩
じゃがりこゴロゴロホタテバｔ
じゃがりこたらこバター
じゃが・・りこ・・じゃなくね
さつまりこ
これもじゃがりこの友達ですよ
じゃがりこＧＲＡＮＤサラダ
じゃがりこをなんかポテトサラダにできるという
話を聞いたんですよ
しってる？
聞いたことはある
あぁめっちゃ簡単ですね
用意するものは
じゃがりこを１つお湯を適量
沸騰させて少し経ったものを入れます
１、お湯を注ぎます
読んで。よくわからん
ほぉ
舐めてんじゃんもう作り方で
で、まぁ今ここにですね結構無数のじゃがりこがあるんですけども
あんまり使わないね
この全種類だけでいいかな
じゃがりこ全種類使って
全てのじゃがりこの味が一つになった
もう極上の味のじゃがりこポテトサラダを
作ろうと思います
では、いこう
まずじゃがりこが汚れないように
しっかりマットを敷きましょう
これぐらいですね
じゃまずはじゃがりこサラダ
しっかりねこう言うのしっかりやっていきたわけですよ
ハンマーやばいよハンマー
え！うぅわえ！もうこれでポテトサラダじゃんもう
もうここにポテトサラダができちゃった感じなんですけど
ちょまさきこれさぁ飛び出るからさ
両サイドこう持っててもらっていい？
やだー
え何で
やっやめろ俺のスマートフォンには
保険がかかって
ない！
割といい感じじゃね
あっホラご覧ください
もう完全にポテトサラダの素です
これはもうポテトサラダですね
ちょっとまだ甘いのでこう言う所をしっかり潰していきましょう
はいというわけで無事にお湯が沸いたのと
じゃがりこが全て粉々になったので
早速これを混ぜて最強のポテトサラダを作っていこうとと思います
おぉー
ちょっと多くね
あやべっあっあっあっあっまさき
やばいやばい
えっどうしようどうしよう
あば
あぁでもぽいね
ちょっとずつお湯を足していきます
細かくしたから早いね
うん
割と先に細かくしたのは
作戦的には成功なのかもしれないです
はい！というわけで無事完成しました
コチラ
じゃがりこ全種類を混ぜて作った
ポテトサラダでございます
やぁー
取り皿をもってこなきゃ
さすがに怒られそうだな
ものさしが！
まな板だわ
こんな感じのポテトサラダになっております
いただきます
んっ
えっポテトサラダだ
美味しい？
うまいうまいよ
なじっ何味かって言われると説明しずらいタイプ
結構おいしい
うまいめっちゃうまい
甘いポテトサラダみたいな味になります
うまい！
ちょっと甘みが入ってるんですよさつまいものおかげで
ぜんぜん味的にはアリな味ですが
ちょっと量が多いので
冷蔵庫に入れて後日、夕飯にしようと思います
というわけで是非ねじゃがりこ好きな人
よかったら作ってみてください
痛っ
なんかじゃじゅうじゃ
普通に刺さったよここ
完全に今やばい鋭利な刃物だったよ
ホラやばいってマジで